muchas gracias
no cabe duda que el destino nos va a
poner
indicadas en los momentos indicados y
eso fue lo que nos sucedió en este viaje
el cual estoy sorprendentemente
agradecido de todo lo que nos ha pasado
les agradezco muchísimo que me den el
tiempo de estar en este escenario y que
empiece la fiesta
todos nacemos con una esencia natural
una esencia que no está contaminada que
no tiene etiquetas que simplemente la
esencia con la que venimos al mundo a
vivir el destino nos espera ansioso pero
que sucede que en la niñez esa esencia
se aflora en el silencio de cada uno de
nosotros yo lo particular vivía mi mundo
de fantasía
en mi mismo tenía mis amigos imaginarios
me imaginaba haciendo cosas
sorprendentes y lo que sucedía alrededor
de mí era que me empezaba a topar con
pared que llamara la atención a todo el
mundo mis papás me estaban cada vez
restringiendo más de lo que debía de
hacer lo que no debe hacer y me
empezaron a etiquetar y a llevar por un
camino que no quería yo caminar así el
niño rebelde se convirtió en adolescente
una adolescente que lo corre donde
cuatro secundarias en una de ellas la
primera con la que me corrieron y papá
daba clases muy vergonzoso para el señor
la segunda otra de secundaria particular
me corrieron a los seis meses era una
persona tan inquieta que constantemente
quería alborotar a todo lo que me
alrededor pero que era lo que sucedía
estaba chocando contra lo que me imponía
el mundo y lo que yo tenía internamente
después de ahí mi papá me dijo ma yo me
voy a meter a la escuela más peligrosa y
violenta de la ciudad investigo era
donde más había broncas donde estaban
los pandilleros más peligrosos y yo
después de venir de escuelas privadas
pues imagínense el choque
vengo llegando a la secundaria el primer
día de clases y decía me van a matar
recuerdo perfectamente bien que venía
con mi pantalón color chevron y mi
camisa blanca y pasé por un patio en
donde cada una de las pandillas tenía su
territorio dividido
a todas las partes y dije ok vamos a ver
cuánto aguanta aguanta un año y medio y
también me corrieron me gané a todas las
gentes que estaban a mi alrededor de mí
y vi fue la primera elección que
realmente entendí no importa quien
tengas enfrente no importa de quién te
rodees para algo esa persona llega a tu
vida y si realmente le entiendes vas a
estar muy bien en donde te toque vivir o
me corrieron esa secundaria de ahí me
dijeron que vamos a hacer contigo
realmente era un dolor de cabeza
ahorita se lo platico así muy light pero
si se lo preguntan a mi mamá va a decir
dijo elena yo qué barbaridad dijeron
pues no hay otra vamos a meter una
escuela de mujeres yo santo dios éramos
cinco hombres y como unas cuarenta niñas
y aparte estaba comercio al lado y como
850 mujeres estudiando comercio y
secretariado llegué al limbo fui muy
feliz terminé la secundaria y los
problemas con mis padres aumentaban cada
vez más mi papá muy enérgico me decía
mayo
definitivamente no vienes a estudiar una
carrera vamos a meterte una preparatoria
técnica y te vas a poner a estudiar
mecánica automotriz para que cuando
salgas de la prepa te pongas a trabajar
no le veo un futuro
mi papá eso no es lo que yo quiero yo
soñaba constantemente con ser empresario
yo voy a la serie de dallas donde salían
los higuaín con una gran corporación y
en todos los bancos pintaba lee
corporation leonardo escobar leal
corporación no sabe lo que significaba
pero pues como los higuaín tenían sus
edificios y todo pues yo también quería
entonces desearle el corporation leal
corporation los chavos que estaban
alrededor de mí decían hay baile
corporation me la creía
total para no hacerles largo descuento
me metieron al cbt y 122 a una hora y
media de mi casa en aquel entonces
vivíamos en chihuahua en la tarde tenía
que tomar tres camiones e ir al cebetis
al cual no me gustaba
adoro la mecánica pero no era mi función
yo quería hacerle el corporation yo
quería ser empresario
todas las tardes me la pintaba y me
chuté todas las películas de picardía
mexicana así que fue estupendo
finalmente a mi padre lo cambian a
monterrey por razones de trabajo y me
dijo seguimos con lo mismo vamos a la
técnica digo papá yo quiero ayudar una
carrera quiero realizarme quiero ser un
empresario dice no vienes a ser una
persona que va a terminar la prepa ya
trabajar ni modo no viniste a cero
estudiantes no viniste a hacer una
carrera como ejecutivo como empresario
no hay ningún problema te va a ir bien
eran tantas las frustraciones con las
que yo vivía que cada día me volvía más
rebelde hasta que un día le dije papá
darme la oportunidad de poder estudiar
lo que yo quiero y hockey tuve a meter a
esto a la escuela técnica pero si en un
semestre me demuestras que quieres
realmente ser un estudiante y para una
carrera vamos para allá es entre todas y
así empezó el cambio de mi vida
es un problema ahora que no era no
significaba estudio porque ahora era
buen estudiante pero quería trabajar
porque para ser empresario yo tenía que
trabajar trabajar y estudiar para poder
realmente obtener la experiencia
toda la contabilidad que tuve alrededor
me metí a estudiar un 90 trabajar a
mcdonald's perdón a una tienda
hamburguesa con una negra nota sí
lo cual me empezó a enseñar a trabajar
16 años y nunca lo deje de hacer hasta
el día de hoy que sucedió después tuve
varios trabajos posteriores nunca deja
de estudiar y trabajar tuve todas las
broncas del mundo con mi papá
constantemente me decía que pues yo iba
a ser un rebelde sin causa y que todo lo
que no le hacía caso pues me la iba me
iba a dar un golpe en la vida
no tenía 21 años
para acá es una depresión muy grande y
una noche me dijo mayo
y admiro mucho porque todo lo que has
sido rebelde conmigo me has demostrado
que aunque tengas un bloqueo constante
en tu vida siempre lo sacas adelante
creo en ti vas a ser grande al día
siguiente mi padre se suicida
ya no tuve oportunidad de enseñarle todo
lo que iba a hacer pero me marco tan
grande tan fuerte esa situación en mi
vida que me hice mucho más fuerte en ese
momento tenía solamente dos caminos a
seguir ser la víctima constante que se
le suicidó el papá o ser la persona que
tuvo una situación en su vida que le
hizo ser fuerte y aprender para poder
lograr su meta de objetivo
si 10 cuando enterramos a mi papá le
digo a mi mamá quiero ser empresario y
tienes un trabajo tenemos un año de
sustento
tu papá no nos dejó gran cosa se nos va
a acabar el dinero en el dinero en un
año pero te apoyo si quieres ser
empresario
adelante me salgo de trabajar abro mi
primera empresa y qué sucede que al año
se nos acaba el capital quiebro
tres meses de que no hubiera allá más
sustento en mi casa
hoy en una avenida ahí en monterrey yo
como un carrito que traía solamente
seguro contra terceros
literalmente pierdo lo único que tenía
si yo que voy a hacer me senté
literalmente a llorar en la banqueta de
esa avenida y le hablo a mi compadre y
amigo él dijo no tengo dinero ni
siquiera para regresarme en el camión
hoy por ti no te preocupes al llegar me
dice mayo mañana será otro día
puedes realmente cumplir tu sueño eres
grande
al día siguiente necesita en el mauricio
y melesio en su oficina y me dicen nadie
hay dos opciones de negocio que están
alrededor de lo que nosotros ya tenemos
una fumigadora o una mensajería ok
todavía con mi sangre de fiesta dijo una
fumigadora así puedo ir a fumigar a
vallarta y cancún y todo y andar con
greñas y la mar
dijeron oye y no crees que suena mejor
leonardo escobar gerente general de una
mensajería a una fumigadora
sí cierto verdad yo creo que nos vamos
por ahí así nació quality post una
compañía de mensajería en mexico que fue
mi segundo negocio y que funde con con
mis grandes amigos foto una historia
fenomenal
fue una historia de mucho aprendizaje
mucho crecimiento llegamos a unos
niveles bastante competitivos en el
mercado pero cuando ya tenía todo cuando
ya no tenía la necesidad económica
cuando ya tenía el haber sido empresario
cuando todo estaba rondando en mi vida
de manera correcta me hacía falta algo
hacía falta algo no me sentía al cien
por ciento realizado
y digo a mi esposa que siempre me ha
apoyado en todo que aquí esté enfrente
de mí y ahora ya no quiero estar en
cuáles tipos
dice como ya lograste absolutamente todo
ya la empresa está súper viento o sea
con los problemas diarios pero porque
ahorita porque ahorita después de que
todo este tiempo ha sido de lucha
1900 realizado y es ahí cuando fue la
primera vez que me di cuenta que venía a
hacer algo que me apasiona no que me
diera dinero no que me diera un estatus
no que me dieran una empresa algo que
realmente me realizaran
una vez más abrí mi tercer negocio vez x
que es el que tengo actualmente fue una
experiencia fenomenal tengo 10 años con
la empresa me ha ido gracias a dedos
bastante bien ha sido una experiencia
bien diferente pero seguía yo con ese
vacío ese vacío que me decía entonces mi
pasión no es ser empresario
está súper bien que tengo un negocio y
que pueda ser realmente responsable con
la manera en que vivo pero me hace falta
algo y ese algo que es empecé a echar
varias locuras sea describir y de
repente me decidí empezar a cantar a los
46 años el mundo me criticaba y me decía
por favor no cantes canta es muy mal
eres muy malo haces el ridículo no
tienes edad todos los bloqueos que
ustedes se pueden imaginar los tenía
enfrente pero yo entre más bloqueos
tenía más me alimentaba a seguir mi
pasión que era cantar
o sea puede seguir cantando y no me
importa y aunque tengo 46 años voy a
seguir cantando esa pasión empezó a
fortalecerse con capacitación me empecé
a meter realmente a estudiar para poder
no llegar a ser un cantante profesional
pero para poder hacerlo por el gusto de
hacerlo y empezaron otras aficiones que
fui descubriendo dentro de ese ámbito
que era estar en el escenario
el año pasado en febrero
se me ocurre la locura
y hacer un canal hacer un programa en
youtube para entrevistar a gente que sea
feliz y exitosa haciendo lo que le
apasiona ha sido por arriba de felicidad
la pasión es constante y la felicidad es
cíclica
tenido tanta respuesta de la gente y no
por la cantidad de seguidores sino lo
por lo que dejas en cada una de las
cápsulas o las entrevistas que haces
estoy lleno eso es precisamente lo que
el vacío que yo tenía esa pasión que me
estaba gritando constantemente que me
sea ser un hombre rebelde una persona
completamente controversial que andaba
por el mundo divagando y que pensaban
que nadie iba a hacer nada digo que no
iba hacer nada esa era la pasión que me
estaba gritando ese será el choque
constante con todos los protocolos que
la vida te pone para ser realmente lo
que quieres hacer
y entonces dije me voy a dedicar
y tener un espacio de expresión para que
por lo que he pasado en mi vida puede
servir de herramienta a la gente que
está en esa búsqueda de su pasión sucede
ahí que me siento realizado me siento
completo que cada una de las personas
que entrevistó dejan algo a esas
personas que están en búsqueda de esa
pasión que me termine de dar cuenta que
eso es lo que realmente te da vida que
es lo que teníamos cuando éramos niños y
no teníamos ninguna contaminación y
ninguna etiqueta eso fue lo que venimos
a hacer a la vida cada uno lo que nos
grita a cada momento pero lo que la
sociedad nos bloquea en cada momento
sean locos equivoquen se atrevan se
porque es lo que realmente te da la vida
como eso que te grita y que te hace
hacer cosas diferentes es lo que te da
lo que realmente necesitas para vivir
y ahí estoy ahorita escribiendo mi
primer libro vamos a sacar un disco
ahora los black sox que es un agrupa de
un grupo de viejitos que la música para
que terminó de hacer terminó formando un
grupo que toca para beneficiencia y
ahora la gente que antes me decía que
por favor no cantará ahora sí va a haber
nos cantaría dejar dinero para donar y
eso me hace muy feliz porque aparte
tengo 6 integrantes del grupo 7 ya
porque cada vez son más porque tengo
hasta trompetas saxofones y todo el
rollo y todos estamos felices haciendo
lo que nos apasiona porque ya como que
bueno tercera edad pero ya no la madura
empezar a cantar y empezar a hacer cosas
como las que estamos haciendo cuando
cualquiera no quiero ser un rock star no
quiero llenar estadios pero si toco y
ayudo canto y ayudo me siento bien
aparte tengo un canal que va a todo dar
que la gente se expresa y el programa se
llama entrevistas hechas canciones
porque cada entrevista le terminó con
una canción inspirada en lo que escuche
y ahí mismo y sin ensayar y todo eso
marca una tendencia en donde real
mente soy congruente y expreso lo que
quiero con lo que hago no voy a dejar de
ser empresario pero todo este camino y
todo este puente que tuve que ellos
seguir para poder descubrir lo que
realmente me apasiona lo tuve que vivir
muchas veces te preguntas es tarde
yo ya soy un hombre tanto una mujer de
tanto y quiero ser bailarina aunque es
tarde
nunca es tarde para empezar y es lo que
tenemos que tener en la mente no seamos
zombies sociales seamos auténticos
guerreros para lograr lo que realmente
queremos hacer porque cuando descubre su
ocupación nada ni nadie se detiene
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]